Piers Morgan is editor at large at Daily
Mail comm and he joins us tonight hey
Pierce how are you talking so what do
you what do you make of this but both of
armor OSes latest incarnation as a
political pundit and of the dismissal of
religion is mental illness well first of
all I find it absolutely ridiculous that
we're even having to discuss Omarosa in
any serious physical context and the
only reason we're doing that is because
she was allowed to have an office in the
West Wing of the White House for nearly
a year I don't know why Donald Trump
would have ever let her in there
she's already behaving exactly how I
could have predicted she would bathe in
other words she's squealing like a
canary and taking them all down as of
course she was going to shizer morosa
she's a reality television star who's
only raised on deck is to be a poisonous
little Viper spreading gossip innuendo
and terrorizing everyone in her wake so
first question what was she doing there
sorry this is a bigger scandal I agree
she worked amorosa works at the White
House really what Democrats didn't even
notice I guess she's too you know she
seems normal to them we have all this
stuff about Rob Porter which is a very
serious matter and it quite clear that
he shouldn't have been there either
given what we now know about him and
there are questions for the
administration right to the top about
who knew what where and when but if
we're gonna apply that logic and
judgment to Rob Porter where was the
same logic and judgment about having
Omarosa with her own office in the West
Wing I mean it is almost beyond parody
and yet there is a serious point to this
tucker which is who is the president
surrounding himself with you know I I
have a lot of time for Donald Trump I've
known him a very long time I met him
when I when I took part on somebody
apprentice with Amoroso
but he's got to have better people
around him in the White House I think
than the types of people we see with Rob
Porter and Omarosa yeah I mean I I think
I'm roasted probably in her own category
I can say having you know but over there
a few times it's not chock-full of our
moroseness but she did work there she
became famous for being horrible I don't
think it's an overstatement
you
you worked with her on the apprentice
what she liked she's absolutely
appalling I mean literally one of the
worst human beings I've ever encountered
in my life a lot of bad people
she has no saving grace she was vicious
conniving scheming plotting treacherous
she she and her first gambit to me day
one first challenge
she sidles up to me I've never even met
this woman and she says to me hey Pierce
we should have a bromance or an
showmance I said what's the show mad she
won't you know she said on the
apprentice everyone has sex together so
you and I could do that and then we
could sell it make loads of money I said
if you are you completely deluded what
please go away she said what what's the
matter with you
are you gay no just because I don't want
to have sex with you on this show that
doesn't make me gay to me for about you
know I'm a victim here I'm a victim of
her Oh sir Tucker but she she gave me
then for four or five weeks unrelenting
five barrels of abuse tea raids and the
phobic stuff a really vicious nasty
stuff and I couldn't believe it I mean
she could she got beaten in the show I
ended up winning it that stuck in her
mind as well cut forward to the campaign
I think in the middle of 2016 I suddenly
read she's gonna be working for Donald
Trump the candid about what how can that
even make any sense then I hear when he
wins she's gonna be in the White House
now I ela again I have a lot of respect
for Donald Trump but I'm afraid with
omorosa this made no sense at the time
it makes no sense now she's left she
apparently achieved absolutely nothing
in her time in the White House of and
disrupting everybody and you can just
bet your life she was there listening
plotting scheming probably tape
recording we're now gonna have Celebrity
Big Brother and all the stuff will come
out of that then we're gonna have the
book then the docu-series and then the
Lifetime movie so I've got which point
you and I are gonna have to leave the
country because it is so ridiculously
absurd that's one of those vivid
descriptions of anyone I've ever heard
have you been in contact with
I suppose you're not texting each other
still you know what we have not stayed
in touch I did bump into a once a No WWE
wrestling event and it's funny the
nausea I felt in the exact moment that
she made that proposition to me all came
flooding back and I literally had to run
to the restroom and regurgitate exactly
what I had done all those years before
you know she is beyond any reproach
she's a professional agita of epic
proportions and probably the least
trustworthy human being ever conceived
on God's earth and for her now to be
laying into Mike Pence about religion
when religion has somehow created this
monster is beyond any sense of realism
you could ever wish to have what a life
you lead running into a morosa WWE is so
fantastic Piers Morgan come back anytime
great to see it